en fait chaque chroniqueur s'est mis
dans la peau d'un animateur ce qu'ils
sont et on va essayer d'être aussi bon
qu'à même si là vous vous doutez bien
que s'attaque le même délire c'est de
stress doit déjà deux trois coups s'il
ya 2-3 peu court regardez attention
c'est parti vous avez su de truie qui
est l'animateur à chaque fois ils vont
rentrer en imitation vous essayez de
trouver attention premiers chroniqueurs
damien canivet ouais ça va et là vous le
dira cette finale elles mêmes idées mais
c'est pas grave parce que c'est un peu
d'amour mal à me l'ont bien sûr
le crémant un caddie kabyle où elle a
dit j'avais pas reconnue mais c'est au
moment de tourner les serviettes de
serre collins a parce que la bande menée
par contre lui c'est un patrick
sébastien avec moins de budget était
malin ça va ça va être long papier vous
[Applaudissements]
allez tout de suite on va accueillir ben
jama gaza alors ce soir vous accueillir
ainsi il ya dix ans il avait la carte
pôle emploi maintenant il a la carte du
spa du sport plazza chez moi sa carrière
est étonnante
il a commencé il ya très longtemps ça va
mais il ya peu de temps à ses 8 on
l'appelle le braqueur sans cagoule
merci d'accueillir cyril hanouna ne sais
pas pour l'instant j'ai reconnu mais il
aurait fallu qu'ils prennent un strip si
l'avant
attention alors elle je vous jure ça a
été hélas toujours son chien ça a été
très dur de franchement elle elle a dit
je vais le faire mais c'est pas mon
délire je vais essayer c'est celle ci
rokhaya diallo alors regarder et s'est
trouvé que les limites
franchement celui qui trouve sur la tête
de ma mère j'ai tout mis dans le
déguisement c'est pas la peine que j'en
fasse plus là ouais c'est vrai et c'est
tout et c'est trouver de crise a dit
gilles verdez gilbert de anne sinclair
n'ont pas du tout sais qui tu es non
vous pouvez proposer dit non allez-y dit
non à dallas ou non gilles verdez c'est
un chanteur je dis non ouais jeanne mas
[Applaudissements]
il avait avoué est celui qui arrive
maintenant je vous le dis il m'a dit tu
alors au coach il m'a dit ah je veux
absolument lui faire parce que j'ai une
blague en plus l'air bien
je suis au top sur lui jean michel mr
essayer de trouver de qui s'élève
attention je suis un indice pour les
téléspectateurs en embrasant emprunt on
en profite pour un match les dom tom
attention c'est top je suis un animateur
petit par la taille mais grand par le
talent j'ai un des plus beaux tizi du
paf je suis tous les jours à l'antenne
en fin d'après midi
je me présente syrie je suis je suis je
suis c'est tout là bas je suis tous les
jours on tait jalousie je m'appelle
syrie
c'est ça la vanne cyril féraud sa bosse
mais pas y échapper il me fait super
bien j'ai aperçu que oui
[Applaudissements]
attention on va appeler tout de suite
alors regardez c'est à gâteau proulx
aussi à gâteau proulx mais rien à voir
avec la personne mais s'est trouvé dans
la peau de quel animateur annie à gâteau
proulx ces parties peuvent être liés à
la coupe de cheveux certains y a pas de
portable à l'antenne merci attaquant
pedro
excusez-moi bon bâton dans l'anus
allez-y salue les loups hockey nikos est
franchement salut luis bienvenus
bienvenue sur l'été pmp music awards
tout où tous les artistes sont là on va
tweak et ce soir on va tout et est notre
invité d'honneur à enrico macias et la
bonsoir locaux
[Applaudissements]
absents
eh bien allez on va on va accueillir une
autre une autre vie une autre jeune
fille qui est avec nous c'est kelly
kelly a lors desquelles il ya fois c est
lundi patrick sébastien a déjà dit non
c'est pas lui vient de la main offert au
revoir non mais faut pas citer
l'émission c'est facile alors que ces
trous des gains à dzeko si vous êtes
laurence boccolini oui merde
bravo
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
à lui j'adore ça va être un drame ça va
être un drame
maxime gagnon est revenu dans le plus
grand du château le nouvel ep mp un beau
château pour un grand roi mais aussi
[Applaudissements]
commenté paul bert alors allez-y
guillaume accueillir apprend pas
cueillir pour accueillir un monsieur qui
s'appelle jean luc jean luc est tout
d'un patrimoine immatériel
on l'accueille je suis content secours
tandis qu'orange pourtant des choco
qu'on veuille ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est évident et qui j'ai
pas mais vous savez pas il a présenté le
loft peut-être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors attention la dernière isabelle
morini-bosc c'est parti ouais alors on
accueille ce soir valérie muster années
ces grosses boules et puis on accueille
aussi ces machins qui nous expliquera le
cour de la mairie
ouais ouais ouais bah là elle a bossé il
est chéri on en a on en a un dernier
plaisir à kayar promenez vous sur le
plateau c'est votre mère alors on en a
un dernier bon alors là vous avez trouvé
tout de suite hein regardez c'est malik
idées à bari des abats si vous suivez si
je reprends goût classique basse et on
peut tourner la caméra de la manipuler
derrière il a mis en place sa lutte et
beauté alors on commence par quoi
aujourd'hui
maxime tu as un scoop tu as un scoop ou
t'as pas un scoop taper chaud on s'en
bat les lacs à l'est vbi bible on n'est
pas sur la tête de ma mère que je vais
tourner ce soir
merci baltard et des grenades
[Applaudissements]
installez boulet s'est réinstallé bout